Prince Harry was bound to face questions
after his summer break he's been
criticized for using private jets
so launching an eco-tourism project in
Amsterdam seemed bizarre I've learned
that we cannot dismiss the idea of
trying to do something just because we
can't do everything we could all do
better and while no one is perfect we
all have a responsibility for our own
individual impact but the question of
whether he's personally doing enough
wasn't going away it's been 99% of my my
life traveling the world by commercial
occasionally occasionally there needs to
be an opportunity based on a unique
circumstance - to ensure that my family
are safe Harry and Megan have faced a
summer of negative headlines for flying
privately to holiday in France and Ibiza
described as hypocritical considering
their environmental campaigning in
Amsterdam other visitors were skeptical
of Harry's intentions you have to be the
role model for it you can't only talk
you have to like it's completely
hypocritical we're from California so we
understand the whole green initiative
and we have a lot of the same things
going on politically within our state as
well a lot of people saying they want
one thing but doing exactly the opposite
he'd flown on a commercial plane to
launch travel east a sustainable travel
project with some of the biggest names
in the industry campaigners say it is a
start everybody needs to leave by
example in every industry you know in
every area and our number-one demand is
for the government to tell the truth
about climate emergency and a lot of the
responsibility I feel fine lies there if
you know people just aren't aware of the
scale of what we're facing they're still
thinking about you know small
initiatives really an innovation to try
and help people but it's it's so much
bigger than that I've traveled with
Prince Harry or many royal tour
the eco-tourism message isn't anything
new now he's married and traveling with
a family there is greater scrutiny on
the causes that he decides to promote
and also the choices that they make in
the lifestyle they lead and the ways
that they travel there is no doubt that
Prince Harry attracts attention and the
criticism he's faced will bring more
attention to this ecotourism venture
there will be many who still expect him
to do more than lead by example Rhiannon
Mills Sky News in Amsterdam